this podcast is supported by patreon
where subscribers get episodes early ad
free and completely unedited this
episode actually does have a bunch of
edits otherwise the unedited version is
on patreon so if you want to support
this very independent podcast go to
patreon.com
I was just I was just watching a video
of yours I was just watching your
Baldur's Gate uh saliva video yeah
I uh
I'm not going to read the comments on
that one
um I just read a couple but I was like
I'm sure I'm gonna make people very mad
with this and I expected to lose a bunch
of subscribers because usually whenever
I take like a a stance that's Pro Dev I
will lose a bunch of subscribers
obviously I keep doing it anyway but I
actually haven't so it's like oh okay
that's interesting
struck a decent balance I would probably
go further and stronger in my opinions
than you did uh so fair play yeah that I
try to do that a lot you know uh and I
also have both perspectives so I get it
um exactly exactly it's a tough one and
it's just like my biggest takeaway from
uh the whole bowl of Skate 3 controversy
really is that from everybody
it sucks that the response is not damn
you guys made a great game I just
I'm contributing to that here obviously
but it like it just must feel so shitty
for larion that everyone is like arguing
about if it's possible to make a game
that good like this I think people are
also assuming their budget is higher
than it was
um
and they just made a really really good
game and it's like I wish that were a
more interesting talking point but
I might have missed I I had a shared
thing but something you said in the
video that matches my experience I might
have just missed a bunch of tweets
because from what I've not seen whatever
the devs saying terrible things was
never crossed my I never saw that like I
saw
I saw what I thought from Salvo was yeah
a thread where there were a couple of
sentences that you can see how they
could be taken out of context if well I
will fully wanted to make you know yes
off video you could absolutely do that
but he still is ultimately just sharing
it inside a perspective it's not I don't
think it's yeah it's not that
objectionable
um
I suspect there may have been some
deleted tweets
um from some devs that's what it sounds
like but then some people will like just
look at the the tweets that were in the
IGN video and I was like those aren't
people being negative above all the C3
and that's honestly that's what that's
what annoys me Choosing My Words very
carefully because I don't want to get
drawn into this although I know I was
the one who started this conversation I
I just I would love it if people didn't
misrepresent people's statements with a
bad faith take uh the headline what they
said of the IGN video
um I like I I don't think is accurate at
all it sounds wrong like five levels
yeah again yeah it's something like
triple developers panicking
not Triple A developer no not panicking
at all he was just trying to like give
people information
um there's enough there's enough hatred
and anger on the internet I don't see
why you manufacture it I really don't no
and now it's generated headlines because
they're so appealing that are along the
lines of like
devs mad at quality video game and like
who like
again for our audience I know our
audience is smart but like when someone
shows you a quick succession of
screenshots of tweets do what Alana did
and pause them and actually read them
they're only two and decide for yourself
if the thing is saying what people are
telling you it says I know I know
destined quite well and again really
liked Destin I had a very good
experience working with Destin
um and
I cannot I understand everything he said
there are things that I think are like
obviously valid for paying customers
customers to be mad at and the games
industry right now and that shouldn't
not to be spoken about because it's
negative like of course not there's
still a lot of criticize game developers
the the toxicities where it gets out of
hand but I still think it's it's fair
um but one thing that I
always did at IGN and uh would always
encourage people to do is just when
you're a journalist never say people are
saying you have to show me where they
said it it's probably like my biggest
editing note is like if you write or say
the sentence as a journalist people are
saying this
delete the take completely unless you
can give me an exact Source or an exact
screenshot of them yes you're being lazy
at worst you're actually it's dangerous
because you're you're creating I just I
whenever I see and this is true of so
many things in like any media that you
consume like whenever I can tell that
the thing I'm reading is trying them or
watching is trying to make me angry I
immediately go well wait a minute there
is value in me being angry let's check
the sources
again the IGN thing I don't know that
Dustin was trying to do that and I would
think he wasn't sourcing it like I would
give him his at best was he was giving
an impassion to take and that wasn't
priority that is what his at best is
um but there's so much [__] on YouTube
it just drives me so nuts of people who
know nothing about game development
speaking about it as though they know
everything and trying to monetize your
anger because it is it works for Fox
News like we know that there's a ton of
money in an audience being pissed off
because then you're emotionally engaged
in invested like there's so much money
in it that they want you to be mad so
bad like
I I just I want I want our games press
to be better than that that's all I want
and I I agree yeah
yeah the the games journalism
should should
I would have approached it again I think
Dustin as well within his rights to make
that and I understand where he's coming
from
um
I would have approached that if I were
writing that article as okay why is this
happening and use my position as media
to interview a bunch of decks um which
is what Destin's response was I think
today
um that he's heard a bunch of the
feedback and he was like I'm going to
reach out to people obviously I
understand if people don't want to talk
to me now but if any Dev wants to talk
to me about Triple A Game Dev then I
would love to and it's also just this
there's a really tough thing about
talking about video games especially
when you work at IGN but I have this all
the time too is
I often feel like people don't actually
want to hear the truth they want to hear
what they make them mad they really
don't like and and we I've seen it in
the comments on our videos before like
people saying I'll be it's so cool that
you guys talk and it would be great if
more devs were open about Dev this is
what happens you know if someone speaks
in a slightly unguarded way for 10
tweets yeah like I know that guy right
like he's elevator he's the best [__]
guy he's so lovely and and he's my guy
which is why I'm getting it which is why
I got a little bit angry about that no
and he's handled it so well like he's
he's such a like
I find him to be extremely like positive
um happy really funny person uh I don't
know if we spoke about it but he had a
game get banned from the Nintendo he's
also occasionally really [__] stupid
the game got banned from the Nintendo
store or at least wasn't allowed to
publish because he had made a bunch of
stupid jokes implying that it was full
of child gambling it's not but because
he basically was just making these like
and our game is definitely not full of
child gambling jokes the game wasn't
published uh he's a he's a good dude who
I suspect like
I think everybody here has made our
mistake um I'm sure I have in my video
too
we've all been you you must have been a
couple of Headlines by this point oh for
sure I mean yeah I I have it's and it's
I suspect that that he didn't realize
how big that tweet was gonna get and is
used to the audience he has and that's a
really tough thing about Twitter and
that's the that's a really challenging
thing right is that like you know
developers developers hang out in space
in social media just like anyone else
does and yeah unfortunately if you're
not guarded if you're not careful if
you're not thinking about how something
could be misread if someone will yes
by people you don't even know like and
it is the thing that you have to think
about and and it leads to that kind of
slow kind of caging up where developers
you learn to just not say stuff in
public which and again itself having
suffers for it yeah like I again I do
feel like people often don't want the
truth right like and that's a really bad
thing that I think has happened to the
relationship between journalist devs and
the audience is
I when I sit down and make a video I
would say like anytime I make a video
like that which I'm trying to do
slightly more where it's like a feature
or like a commentary about news drama I
will often have to edit out myself
saying the sentence I know you don't
want to hear this
I say it so often that I know I'm just
saying it for myself it's like it
doesn't need to be in the video it
doesn't help you're giving yourself
permission to say the thing you're
saying I just say it all the time that
I'm like I know you don't want to hate
this I know that the take that the
YouTube wants to hear the the mass
YouTube audience wants to hear is
Dev lazy and bad and I know that and
that is often not the truth
um but it's something what it is to be
first yeah and that's the thing where I
was like is true no one can spot it
because of all the times they've been
lied to yes it's like a a boy who cried
wolf is that's the thing that I think I
did mess up in in my videos like I
didn't address that there literally are
lazy devs uh or like oh like I have
friends who work at Studios who've
spoken about like terrible management
and that is the death causing the
problem and that happens all the time
it's like okay that's the thing that I
should have mentioned where I've
misspoken
um happens all the time but it's it's
just a really tough landscape where
things have generated clicks now for
anger at devs
and I so badly wish the anger was
directed at better causes and like
there's a part of that video that I
edited out
um that's easy to talk about here
where I was like well I don't want to
put the any of the onus on players to
feel like they have to answer to the
industry's mistakes
but
none of the squabble matters to the
publisher they don't care they don't
care about any of your mad tweets and
people that you as a game player
actually should be annoyed at don't you
socially no they don't care
they don't care about anything you're
saying and like they're like yeah Justin
speak up to them then I give a [__]
about what Dustin's saying the way to
actually make a difference and and this
is a problem that even I have as a
consumer that like if I left Dev
tomorrow I'd be doing the same thing is
to stop spending money but Publishers
know they will like the people who
complain about FIFA every year about it
not changing enough still buy FIFA every
year and the publisher knows you're
gonna buy it every year so why would
they care about what you say on Twitter
it's effectively cyber bullying I'm like
stop pre-ordering stuff sorry it's like
except for Bissell games
and Sony first party games
uh everything else not so much
uh will also allow any Austin wintry
property uh otherwise
[Laughter]
um but also ask for refunds if you don't
like something
don't keep playing it and I think that's
the thing that's happened with um a lot
of the Diablo controversy is like
they know you're still gonna [__] put
hours into that game and spend money on
it so why it doesn't matter nothing you
say matters at all and again I don't
want to put onus on players
to fix what is a capitalism problem like
that's it is a publisher issue that that
people don't get enough time or don't
have enough budget to execute on their
plans that that's the way it is but the
only way to actually punish the
Publishers and make a change to the
system is to stop spending money or to
take your money back when you have spent
it and to stop just buying the same
stuff that you complain about but
Publishers no game is going to do it
it's not games it's all very it's so
it's something that's always existed
like it's and it's the oldest trick in
the book actually powerful people don't
play the game they step back from the
game and they let everyone else fight it
out you know you are if you're angry
somewhat about anything be it a game be
it an issue whatever someone is
profiting off your anger unless you're
careful about where you direct that
anger and and yeah so getting angry at
an indie developer getting angry at any
developer getting any angry anyone who
you are aware of or who you have access
to on Twitter and being mean to that
person is not going to solve anything
it's not going to get the thing you want
changed and if anything the people who
are actually responsible for whatever it
is in games that you don't like those
people as you said Lana they're nowhere
nearby and they actually benefit from
you focusing your anger on someone they
can easily fire and then you say they're
brilliant for doing so like it's so
Insidious and it's a loop that if you've
been in the industry long enough you
just see it happen over and over again
um and the the actually bad people just
continue to be bad
um behind the scenes in the shadows in a
way so bad like I don't really know what
the solution is like I think probably
the most disagreeable thing that I would
have said to
um gamers in that video
is yes I think you should have higher
standards
I don't think they will often matter
like I think you can have as high
standards as you want and I love video
games and think we should expect the
best in video games because it's such a
[__] awesome medium and we can create
so much cool stuff and there are so many
benefits to video games that don't exist
in other entertainment mediums
um but me having high expectations of
Platinum Games is probably my favorite
developer they just shut down a game
because it performs so poorly like they
still have like such a good track record
of games that I love and they still made
one that effectively was terrible and
they kind of knew it was terrible it's
like my expectations can be through the
roof as it is with them
it just doesn't change anything and and
you can complain when things don't meet
your expectations
that game got shot you should you should
complain also I should say I don't like
this game you should you should say that
publicly you should talk about it the
problem is when it comes to when it's
when it's people rather than product
product you can be disappointed in and
dislike oh totally like a product even
feel free like leave a bad review do
whatever yeah thankfully I've also not
seen anybody harassing any of the the I
don't doubt it exists but I actually
haven't seen any of that either I
haven't seen anyone harassing any of the
devs who've spoken about this uh on the
internet
um because at least like distance video
he's not naming anyone
um I mean he puts up people's names on
screen when he's talking to be clear
sorry yeah yeah but he's not saying [__]
this person uh putting names up on
screen is something we want him to do
that though that's him sourcing we want
him to Source the things well sorry and
then misquoting this so anyway we won't
go there he did Miss vote
sources uh
um but no it's I think I think yeah I
think I think I like to believe and I
hope this is true I've not talked to
saliva about this I should I will
I suspect a lot of people see the thing
get angry about the thing then go to
that developer go to that thread and
then read it as you didn't go
well he's not said
he's not attacked the thing he's not
said that I should he's not saying
what's being said here
first actually
yeah so I think a lot of people will
have done that I think a lot of people
will have gotten their blood I've seen
reactions to the IGN thing
um from uh I saw um most critical uh the
most critical I always get confused what
that guy's name is Charlie yeah Charlie
yeah yeah
yeah and he largely agreed with the kind
of the sentiment Express but he took
pains to say in the video but I don't
think this Dev is like being a dick and
it's that kind of I think that that
people who then come in with kind of a
critical eye on this stuff and look at
what the source says I think there's no
there's no fire there there's definitely
been cases of developers saying
something stupid on Twitter harass for
it correctly so but like understandably
so yeah this isn't one of them no not at
all nothing really worthy of frustration
so no I think I like I think the
audience on the whole probably realized
that once they actually read what he
said so I 100 think Destin when talking
about this should name the people and
show the things he's talking about
um I do think he misrepresented
what he was saying or misunderstood
um I think I would Veer on misunderstood
to be clear like I think I think he
misunderstood and yes but there's you
know there is a big consequence when you
all of us have platforms all of us have
to think about how we represent other
people's opinions
yeah and again I think that the initial
tweets also could have been phrased a
little differently oh he definitely had
some stuff in there that was like oh
just tweak that the first one to be
honest is really the only yeah the only
real issue and it's also like he does
credit
um
the DND IP for some of the success of
Baldur's Gate 3 uh but they didn't get
funding from Wizards and I don't I would
think most
Gamers don't know that Baldur's Gate is
a d d property
um that's interesting do you do you
think the association doesn't I guess
it's not is it it's a fair point how how
would it even like get traction from it
like it's not getting SEO like it's
I only people who've played a ball this
gate game or have looked it up so
therefore they would already apply it's
a fair point I don't know enough about
kind of the DND overlapped uh but yeah
no they wouldn't have they wouldn't have
funded it no it's a licensing deal I
imagine just a standard kind of we pay
you money we use your stuff kind of deal
yeah and I think most of their money
probably came from a very successful
Early Access which again like is the
thing that I would love to see the
industry take away from this whole
conversation which in the end of the day
I'm glad we're having again aside from
the fact that I wish the conversation
was more just about how [__] awesome
skit 3 is and I just feel bad Valerian
but
um oh I'm sure they're fine with it oh
yeah absolutely successful brilliant
true I I would be surprised if they
don't get game of the year but it's so
hard to say that when stockholds just
but the only answer this is a key part
right is like I remember the Early
Access launching and there were there
were people in the Press who were like
giving it bad reviews and stuff and kind
of oh were they I don't remember that
rap buddy yeah totally I I think Early
Access is something that we're still not
brilliant
and I understand it I all the access I'm
really torn on because I totally get the
player kind of perspective I also partly
don't know you're taking money therefore
it better be good I totally respect that
but at the same time it's it also is a
work in progress so I don't know I don't
think we've worked out quite well
I don't think we've worked out how to
explain early access to the audience and
how to make the old early audience be
early access comfortable for the
audience so I'm not sure how I feel
about Early Access and then
it obviously uh would have helped them
fund development and thus I feel like
it's very solid for Indies um
but you are also charging full price for
an incomplete product and I don't know
how it feels like we've never done it is
I've never been super sure where we
should fall on that so we've just we've
never done a game that way because of
the exact challenges you're talking
about like I don't know where I stand on
it so you're like as media I know that
some Outlets do but like I wouldn't know
the the solution if I were a reviews
editor is like do we review Early Access
games
because
people can buy them yeah people people
have a right to know right like if
they're if it's a product that's for
sale I like I said that's the thing is I
I would like that to be the discourse we
were having right now of kind of
unpicking that much more interesting
much more interesting it's like the
ethics of Early Access yeah because it's
I really don't know the answer like I
think I'm uncomfortable with it I think
that like charging full price for
something in Early Access
it's obviously beneficial to the dev
team and at the end of the day if it
helps make a better video game that's a
huge win
but I'm
also just don't know how that falls
ethically with consumers like oh they're
paying you to Beta tests
that's a weird one like because I'm
really not sure the best equates I can't
remember who said this to me but someone
because I had I've had this conversation
many times because I'm fascinated by it
even though we've never done it
ourselves
be equating it to like a TV show it's
one of the cool things about making a TV
show versus a movie is the first few
episodes go up and you see that audience
reaction and it's a real reaction
because they're people watching TV with
commercials and the whole setup and
experience and you can kind of see
what's happening with your first few
episodes while you're either writing or
in production on like later stages of
that show and you can kind of steer and
like you'll often see this in like the
first season of a show like about
halfway through the show like oh that
character no one likes suddenly has less
scenes does that work that way
like a lot of Seasons done
I'm talking about like the old 20 24
episodes of season kind of days those
kind of all 20 or 20 well vary but I
guess I always assume the production
pipeline was writings done first
um no no no I suspect it probably is now
with the kind of The Limited length like
10 episodes or less structure that we
have now because of streaming I imagine
it's it's less cut and dry but no there
were like there's definitely a lot of
historical like accounts of like a show
like Buffy the Vampire Slayer that would
be the First episodes of the Season
would be sharing while they were still
had time to adjust or fix things
that would be the way that that would
roll through well I know Sopranos when
um spoilers
haven't finished the season it's pretty
old spoilers I guess uh when Tony's mom
dies because the actress actually died I
think that season is a mess uh and it's
because they clearly didn't know how to
respond to it they don't know really the
script is like uh this and nothing
sticks they have like all these
conflicts that are resolved in the same
episode
um it it comes across this very
incomplete because somebody died which
like doesn't happen anymore I guess you
just adjust from the top if somebody
dies
the shows are made a lot faster in the
current climate which is part of the
discussion happening around the uh the
the strikes at the moment as well like
things are made very quickly so you
could so yeah things would be adjusted
by on the fly but my point is what's
what's good about that old model of TV
production was that you could learn or
even just between like season one and
season two you kind of course correct
and change how you're doing things but
you were getting data from an audience
who actually engaged it's not like going
to say a focus group where it's a bunch
of people who've not paid for the game
they're playing it in a weird
environment they're they're they're
answering questions in a weird room with
a person who's interviewing them there
is something to be said for what's
someone who's put down money for this
game and is loading it up on their home
games console or PC having a true
experience what does that person respond
to and like and that's very good
valuable data so I think you can make a
compelling argument that a game like all
this game yes they made money during
Early Access which is awesome but I bet
a lot of the things that right now
everyone's loving about the game were
also arrived upon as part of the
feedback they were getting from our
community early on they were they were
balancing they were figuring this out
especially with something as complex as
an RPG where there's so many balancing
challenges and have you played it
maybe they just cast every British voice
actor basically in some role in there
and they all do a great job yeah I mean
it's a huge it's a huge game like it's
massive but it's like I can't do right
now I don't have any free time I'm I am
deep in work that I can't talk about
shut up lazy Dev I know I wish If I Only
Had passion for games if I played games
play video games it's a thing though
I've not played I'm not playing anywhere
near enough games right now I um it's
it's the thing another thing you said in
your video the uh that joke about the
person who's played the game over the
weekend and comes in pitching the idea
like that is
that is such
and and specifically a joke about
creative directors I think more than
anyone else gets that like my team that
literally was a joke someone made about
me in a meeting today it happens so much
like it's like Mike's Xbox one maybe Deb
should learn something from Bowlers gate
three I promise you there are a bunch of
like level designers who are pissed off
because someone was like look at the
verticality now to play boulders
also true yeah but like Elden ring was a
was a big one uh
like that definitely came up all the
time uh in meetings and you can tell you
you can tell a Dev cycle you can work
out how long a Dev cycle is at any given
Studio by when the first game they had
come out they had an elder ring mechanic
in it was and basically tracking it back
and going okay in this game coming out
in 24. so you can track how long a Dev
cycle was based on the proximity
to uh release of a Zelda game
whenever the most recent Zelda came out
a bunch of [__] changed
it will it will be something that
probably someone who's never worked in
game development probably this is I'm
about to ruin all games for you is is
like if there isn't if there is a
mechanic that is so awesome and special
that everyone loves it it's going to be
the cliche in three years from now and
it's so funny when you see like
especially this is very noticeably open
world games but like an open world game
will come out in this year and that will
have a mechanic that blows everyone away
and then then the year after that no
other game will have a mechanic and
everyone will complain that mechanic's
not there yeah and then the year after
that everything will have that mechanic
and everyone can claim it's now overdone
except nobody do the Nemesis system
wasn't it uh no one had done it before
the patents and then sometimes have a
good idea first yeah it was like there
were several years before they refiner
before I can steal it
I think I should be expected game
developers should not be expected
players need to lose this expectation
that developers will come up with ideas
that's incredibly
um
dare you
someone take that Clipper
that's not in my job description come on
now
there is like some stuff that I've come
to to meme where
Game Dev ideating is concerned and that
I'm so like hostile to it and like one
of them is the blight
why is every game gotta have a [__]
blight there's some sort of like the
sickness like it's always there's just
some [__] existence muck that's
spreading on the land that you have to
say like stuff like that that I'm like
yeah
you know that's a narrative challenge
that's because you need to have a reason
for them to not be able to explore yeah
100 the reason a reason that
everything's affected if it's just a
bloke if you've just got space Hitler
then it's like well we can we can have
like fights with that character that
character could be somewhere leading an
army or whatever but if you need the
whole of the world to be affected you
yeah blights are very easy 100 no way it
exists we just gotta sort out the amount
of [__] blights we've got out here
y'all
effects you just have to make it a bit
more visually somebody do something else
you know they can't it can't all be the
sickness the corruption how many
Corruptions are there it's it just use a
different word like it's just stuff like
that that ends up I get I get why it
exists I get that that's easier to
explain and that players probably
largely don't care they're like cool got
it can't go there that's why I'm
actually obligated to say that Kingdom
Hearts has the best narratives ever they
got some life cannot be faulted uh love
will save us it's a beautiful thing
that's that works both for Disney and
for every Kingdom Hearts fan who you
never want to upset
um that's that that's a community I will
never upset on the internet you don't
even don't even worry about it I tweeted
uh I tweeted once that I don't know
anyone who just sort of likes Kingdom
Hearts you either think it's ridiculous
or you have three keyblades and I had so
many friends who are Kingdom Hearts fans
like send pictures of their three
keyblades it's always three things
I like that the darkness what is it in
Kingdom Hearts it's not the blight it's
um the heartless there you go uh it's
just yeah it's just such a common Disney
fans strong identity it's out now
I know you're I I know you're wrong
I went back and uh I looked I've
actually got some Kingdom Hearts Tron
toys up on the Shelf like oh I went and
look there's genuinely some really good
Tron stuff in Kingman so so yeah which
ones
that's where that's where I get confused
the numbering system does confuse me a
little bit no it doesn't it makes
perfect sense I'll admit the weakness on
my part when it comes to the amount of
controversies the number of title
options you have for this episode to get
the vaccine minutes
Kingdom Hearts two numbering nonsense uh
he is in Kingdom Hearts too
um Tron himself but I'm sure there are
levels in other yeah there's one where
there was this one where they do Legacy
and one where they do the original movie
um and both are really nicely handled
um also it's something you do when
you're when you're trying to work out
how how do we render a Tron World in a
video game you go back to all the other
people who've ever done that problem and
kind of look at you know lots of pouring
over screenshots and videos and going oh
there's a lot of blue lights in it
that was our main conclusion yeah lots
of blue lights stick a blue light on it
I could send you hundreds of pages of
docs of my team painstakingly working
that stuff out
in conclusion
just months of developments
um blue Neons really yeah that'd be
right it'd be fine
the amount of Dev time I've wasted
hey I'm here if you need it I can't be
expected
[Laughter]
yeah it's uh it's been a really weird
controversy to blow up this big because
it's um
so mild in the grand scheme of things
like what do people are actually saying
like I don't know it's a it's a very
weird one but it's obviously taking the
Internet by a storm
um it's well there's no there's nobody
it's kind of like the blight it's what
we're saying before is there's no Mecca
Hitler to fight it's the blight it's
it's not yeah right yeah but they're
talking about different both sides are
right but talking past each other
there's not really a a baddie who's done
a bad thing so it doesn't Tire in the
same way as that happy that both of them
are speaking about the things they're
speaking about
um but
also understand
why it caused issues and again
wish that there was just more positive
about larion but I still think that um
that's the thing someone I someone said
I saw someone saying I think about seven
different controversies ago is the game
lasts people will remember Baldur's Gate
3 is like a masterpiece no one will
remember any of this a week from now
that's true now like it's it's the the
work itself always kind of outlives the
the drama just makes me wish we could
fix the communication problem like I
don't know how to fix it like there's so
much issues miscommunication is probably
unfortunately the the honest answer
that's what I always assumed would
happen to cdpr like they were so
transparent about the development of
cyberpunk and that is actually where
they went wrong it's like for all of us
who are previewing that game I think I
played it I played it once and saw it
behind closed dose twice and I don't
I don't believe they ever lied to me I
think everything that they had ever said
to me that I then said they told me this
they believed would be in the game
um yeah and we've been through we should
have Cycles now as well so you
understand
[__] changes it constantly yeah yeah I
mean
like week to week stuff like that's one
of the harder things of the job that I
didn't expect is keeping track of what
is still exists and what doesn't in my
brain I mean you don't have a perfectly
maintained game design document that is
always up to date and true to what the
current state of the game is working on
it man talking to me it's
it's
the the thing they did is in theory what
we want which is be super transparent
and talk a lot about what they're doing
the problem is that they didn't have the
pr in place that most Studios have to be
like hey you can't say that no man's Sky
did the same thing though I think maybe
a little bit mortgage but they basically
like just well that's not there anymore
but when it becomes when it's taken as
advertising you can't do that so like we
have this weird level of like the devs
are trying to be transparent but all of
it's taken as marketing so if stuff
isn't in it that they thought would be
in it and the plan changes that's lying
to Consumers so it's like I don't think
anyone intentionally liked they were
wrong
but yeah now when you're making
something when you're in pursuing any
creative endeavor
this iteration there's things there's
cul-de-sacs you realize oh that's
working that's not working and yeah I
think unfortunately
I don't think the audience wants us to
communicate all of that stuff I think
the audience probably does want stuff
that's quite that's that's tells them
about stuff but it's polished one thing
well I've had a lot of I've had a lot of
conversations over the years like behind
the scenes I don't think I've even said
some of this publicly like I would love
us as an industry to be like say the
film industry where they announce a
movie years before they start a bunch of
time before they even start shooting it
because there's no way to hide the
production of a movie like there's just
too many moving parts and physical
locations Etc so movies get announced
and that's the point I'm saying because
I've always been on the side yeah
exactly or they get canceled or if if it
was the norm if every game of everside
production was announced and then a
bunch of them just got canceled in the
same way as films do the audience would
kind of accept it and be a thing they
would require all of us to do it all at
once which will never happen no so I've
always I've always wished for that I've
always wished that we could just be
completely open I'm I'm in this fun
position right now where everyone knows
I'm working on Tron so I don't have to
like worry about blurting that out in
conversation yeah but that was like
months of like even on this show of
having to be careful about that like
yeah but but it's nice because now I'm
working working on the next thing and I
can just I I can't say anything about it
but I can say people know why I'm
working and it's and that's that's
lovely but at the same time like if I
came on here and I was like and here's a
cool idea we're working on right now and
then that gets removed two weeks later
because we realize oh [__] that won't
work on platform again it becomes
it's not a lie it just becomes false
advertising a little which is why it's
really complicated it's like so I think
honestly yeah I think honestly the end
result of these kind of controversies is
that it definitely incentivizes
developers just to not so cdpr should
not have shared as much as they did that
is where they went wrong
um their goals were unrealistic which is
obviously an internal problem
um I still [__] love that game but uh
they they overshared in a way that to me
was a delight like I loved getting all
of that information and having all the
devs yeah like be interviewed throughout
that process rather than afterwards it
was so nice
but it was also probably their biggest
mistake outside of watching the game
when they did on Console
um I think it's unfortunate if you could
if you could go to every single person
who cared about your game and like sit
them down and go okay
this is we're going to talk about this
I'm going to be transparent but at the
same time with game development for lots
of reasons things shift as you're going
through the process and sometimes that
will be for good reason sometimes it
will be for bad reasons you'll never
know sometimes it'll be because I'm a
lazy idiot and I make a mistake you know
and have that real 20-minute talk with
every single person in the audience I
think most people on an individual basis
would go oh yeah that's fair enough yeah
tell me about what you're putting in the
game that's really exciting but the
problem is once it's a crowd you can't
do that you can't rely on the audience
to have that knowledge and why should
they no and you'd have to remind them
every time no it and that's that's part
of it you know what that's how we ended
up with the disclaimer not actual
gameplay footage on so many game
trailers and because that had to be
restated enough and now that's a cliche
now you see that it's like well no I
know that's not gameplay footage but for
the longest time that was the
controversy the people felt that those
trailers were lying to them so it's it's
I don't want to have to do those kind of
I don't want like a little scrolling
piece of text underneath my head at all
times going Mike is talking excitedly
about things he hopes to yeah it's also
just I there's a lot of stuff that I
don't actually think should be on the
player
um I don't
I don't like even though I'm sure I've
done it a bunch of times the hey game
dev's really hard when it comes like in
a statement to the public
because I've had other jobs and they're
harder than Game Dev I'll throw that out
Fair it is it is I think
very hard for me personally it's not the
hardest job but it's like the hardest
task for sure is working on I guess my
point is we don't accept that about
other professions
hey hey everyone this is really hard
really hard exactly wait for your beers
I'm having a hard night no one cares
they want them no no it should never be
on the player's mind they it is not the
player's problem that it's hard like is
it hard yes do I think that we are in a
pretty weird position as an industry
where most of the consumers don't
understand the process of making video
games yeah I think people have more of
an understanding of how films are made
or how TV shows are made than they do
video games
um never not going to be frustrated by
again especially because I used to do it
YouTubers talking about Game Dev as
though they know what they're talking
about just because they've been on
YouTube for a long time well that's the
and I I don't know maybe I'm ignorance
I've never I've been on film sets but
I've never worked on a film so I don't
know at the the intricacies of it so
what I'm saying about saying might be
massively ignorant at least with film
the fundamental mechanics of making a
film are relatively consistent in the
sense of there's a camera and you
pointed at some stuff that happens and
then you do some visual effects if you
need to on that footage and then you cut
it together and it's a film whereas in
games like
that's the reason I I saw someone saying
this the other day was widen more game
devs not do why are there not like
YouTube channels from game devs where
they explain how games were made by
other people it's because any qualified
Game Dev knows they can't tell you how
another person's game was made because
it kind of made in 100 different ways
yeah if anyone's anyone who presents
themselves as I understand how games are
made is immediately setting themselves
up to look after to the community
because you don't yeah you can't do the
Inception how did they get that shot
well they just spun the room
it's not that practical that like
Christopher Nolan could watch an
Avengers movie and go I tell you how
something was done yeah I bet he could I
can't do that for another Game Dev I
can't even like even if we limited to
just Indie Games in my budget range I
when you know we've been hiring recently
and when we're talking to people who are
hiring I would say half the
conversations I have in interview user
just so how does it work when you work
like that's a studio I've always liked
the work of and they'll describe it
it'll be
miles away from how we do things or how
how I've ever seen even the questions
that I get most often now that I'm in
Dev is like what's the process for this
or like how do I apply for a games
writing job like depends on the studio I
couldn't tell you like it's so vastly
different
um like what's it like being a games
writer well probably very different at
SMS to it is it Bethel games like the
process for everybody is so incredibly
called Mike Bethel which yeah you have
to be Mike Bethel which is like been a
real challenge for me actually
um I've been meaning to talk to HR there
about that it's like it's been really
tough for me before you see Mission
Impossible it's like that everyone has
to put that on
it's falsely different and that uh makes
it tough for anybody to speak about it
with any level of authority
um but I still you know again for all of
my frustration again knowing I used to
do it I can't believe it's the weirdest
thing to me that anybody listened to
anything I said at IGN about game
development ever just because I had
visited a few Studios and spoke to
people
well I don't [__] know what I was
talking about and I like why do we so
why do we listen to anybody it's so
weird but the reason they listen to you
Alana I'm sure I'm sure the reason they
listen to you and I remember seeing
stuff from you at IGN
um was
it's the humility you're bringing that
makes that like if you come if you're a
journalist who's covering games and you
come in with that humility and you talk
about games in that way and you
interview people and you talk to people
and you you present which I do feel like
journalists tend to have more than
YouTubers which is why they become
journalists probably yeah I mean yeah
maybe but the but I think that's I think
that's a that's a big part of it I think
I don't expect I don't expect uh anyone
who doesn't work in games to fully
understand how games are made I don't
know and we can't and I don't expect
people who work in game Studio 8
understand how games are made that
description but if you go in with that
humility and that desire to learn then
that's awesome and you can kind of and I
think that can be presented really well
I love the people I like who talk about
games and like podcasts YouTube uh
websites they are they they walk into
the room like they're a student they
walk in to learn from what they're
seeing probably why so many journalists
end up working at Debs is because that
they that they're good ones right yeah I
always figured out that I would end up
making the switch because I liked
writing fiction so much my whole life
but uh my favorite thing to do at IGN
was
um called IGN first which is like mini
documentaries so I visited a bunch of
studios and I would interview people and
it was my favorite thing and that's when
I was like man I really like game
development huh like I'm very interested
in this I need to go do that
um and and that stuff is interesting but
uh to my point I don't know 20 minutes
ago I think a lot of that shouldn't be
on players players don't need to know
how hard the thing was
um it it there's no point where telling
the person who's spending money on your
game that it's hard like yes I think
there's a lot of very interesting
contexts that I think it would be
helpful if players knew all were open to
but being like it's just it's just
really hard to do that I just it's not
their problem
yeah I've asked my like not online
friends who play games but like don't
interact with anything like what do you
actually want to know about a game
before it comes out and everyone's
response is always some screenshots tell
me what the gameplay is like give me a
trailer that shows me kind of what the
Vibes are maybe an interview with with
you about what's in it and that's fine
like there's not
I don't I think transparency is
something that a hardcore audience
really cares about and I love that yeah
there are ways of them getting that
information through I guess things like
this as well like that's cool but the
vast majority of the audience just wants
to be entertained and they want as much
information going in as they can get
that's going to honestly depict what the
experience they're getting is I was
listening to um yeah Chris Macquarie who
who uh writes and directs Mission
possible or the last few Mission
Impossibles he does a there's a British
podcast called Empire well Empire
magazine that's in America as well but
the um they do like these long form
interviews with him and they've got
longer each time so they interviewed for
him with the new movie is nine hours
long which is amazing someone who's a
fan of like I love listening to like
directors talk because there's so many
overlays how did they even do that it's
a but it's nine hours of just like I'm
gonna tell you he likes to talk you you
don't know anyone like this it's like
nine hours of him just talking about
Prince I mean it'd be really easy to
interview Austin for nine hours to be
fair like that would be
but like I think that's I think but one
thing but one thing he points out is
that that he and Tom Cruise like their
their focus is that bigger audience
rather than the filmers he's a film nerd
he loves talking to film nerds he's
doing this nine hour interview for film
nerds but he knows that the audience is
actually beyond that mostly aren't that
different mostly on yeah so then they
just want honest entertainment
ultimately yes and again that's why I
think we shouldn't burden players with
its heart like it's just never say it
like it is
um and I don't think many of them know
how hard it is and and it's my gut
response to why didn't they just [__]
do this because so much of it is trust
me they tried or somebody thought of
that it was impossible
um but that leaves me with what do we do
about this communication problem if if
it feels like Gamers hate devs Gamers
hate journalists journalist hate gamers
like this these three separate parts of
this industry and publishes just not
making money
um are so angry at each other I don't
know what the solution is because like I
would have said transparency and I think
that that is what I thought until the
cyberpunk stuff happened to where
transparency was their biggest problem
where they were too transparent with the
exception of I always want to bring this
up the um
they got a lot of [__] for saying it
runs surprisingly well on Console when
it ran terribly on console that was an
investor call like that's that was not a
public-facing comment that was not said
to press uh he didn't tell Gamers it
runs surprisingly well on Console he
said it to investors also in this is why
we need some kind of glossary if we do
do the transparency is it runs
surprisingly surprisingly well when you
say that
one of our builds I mean 15 frames a
second 100 oh my God and and like that
that yeah that is a thing that's also
not the fault of the consumer or the
media that they quoted that because he
said it doesn't know that every game you
first run it on a console you're lucky
if it hits five to ten frames a second
one of the First videos I may optimize
the [__] out of it forever and ever ever
so surprisingly good it's super negative
it just had been yeah what he meant was
it's really bad like that and one of the
First videos I ever made about basically
I said there's no way this game runs on
Xbox One and PS4 I'd be surprised if it
runs on Console at all like it seeing it
on PC I was like there's no [__] way
so then when I see the quote from again
an investor call of someone saying it
runs surprisingly well that translates
very directly to me as this doesn't run
it's bad but we have but it's there yes
um but it's not on the consumer or the
public or even the media that that thing
he said in public uh has a different
context and that's like a whole I think
I think yeah so for me it's it's about
context
um and how do you explain the context of
that quote you can't I think I think I
think I think a journalist in my opinion
and this is you know I I'm telling
journalists I'll do their job while
saying that they shouldn't tell us I'll
do that so I understand the hypocrisy
here I think a journalist should provide
that context a journalist should reach
out to the developer and be like you
said on a public vesicle there was
surprisingly good on Console so I I'm
you know that's a quote I'm going to run
would you like to provide any context to
what that means well you know obviously
a CD project a couple of counter points
for you okay go for it first the
journalists did note that it was not an
investor call
um that doesn't mean anything to to the
audience the but the amount of
editorialization that would be required
to be like an investical is a specific
thing surprisingly well is a negative
um is also like just too much of a leap
second if you are cdpr that question
because they wouldn't have expected that
quote to go public the answer that they
have to give is nonsense like once the
quote is out there the journalists can't
really help them with the quote like
once it took off and it did take off in
headlines you can reach out to them and
be like what did you mean by this and
they're not going to be like we meant
like in Dev terms surprisingly like I
can't there's no correct answer to that
so it's like the minute they said it it
was for the world to hear so the only
solution is not to say it but that's
that's the issue is like that's the only
thing if their downfall was was
transparency but then at the same time
we want more transparency so that people
understand a little bit more about how
games are made so they can like stop
with the why did you [__] do this
like it's just the problem is that the
because I've heard the same thing like
we just want to know how games are made
so that we can understand
games are complex to make I'm not saying
that to show off you know they're much
less complex to make than other things
but they are complex
so I can't educate every audience mem I
can't be confident that every audience
member is going to know how games are
made so that they can contextualize
anything that comes out so ultimately my
only choice is just not to engage and
not say anything in that situation if
I'm CD projekt Red I just can't say
anything about the games
until it's 30 FPS and then I can say
that you know yeah but but that I guess
I I agree that actually the solution is
less transparency unfortunately but that
leaves us with
why did they do this stupid Debs why
have you made this decision and I guess
the reality is
you just have to let that happen like
you just have to yeah no I think I just
don't like the landscape that we're in
and like this is such a weird thing with
criticism I'm okay oh for sure and when
the game's out if it's not good you can
criticism and harassment are not the
same thing like they're not the same
thing criticisms are allowed so the
harassment is the thing to solve but I
think if someone if someone wants to
harass if someone wants to like be mean
to a person for no point on the internet
I'm not sure any degree of transparency
I think that was a lesson we all learned
in the whole dream again thing of like
because I that was a mistake I made
early on was I tried to like go well
actually you know fixing games Germans
and this is really reasonable and I
realize very quickly that well not as
quickly as I should have oh they don't
want to engage they don't want to learn
they don't want to have a conversation
about the Nuance of this so I have
something they're just looking for a
reason to be yeah I'll be like there is
no point in engaging in this
conversation because I'm aware they
don't give a [__] what I have to
saying I'm embarrassed how long it took
me to learn that lesson but once I had
learned that lesson I did the same thing
with gaming gate Mike I engaged with
them and they were all very nice to me
is very weird but I did it because I was
like I want to understand your
perspective for a very long time um we
were stupid babies but we learned our
lessons and we and that's that's the
thing unfortunately is that that's
that is the I don't like the takeaway
here like one of mine neither do I one
of the things I really don't like is
that there's this like people who buy
video games or Gamers but if you're a
Dev or a journalist and you buy video
games you're not a gamer where does it
come from that people think game devs
and journalists don't play games they do
why they do it I play even though you
just say I'm not playing enough games at
the moment but yeah except for you fake
gamer Mike Bethel everybody else in the
industry is playing games yeah I would
love that to be the thing from now on if
like let's be honest here okay game
developers play games except Mike except
for Michael everyone else yes yes if we
could just do that now no I think that's
the level of transparency we want to me
that demons that assumption if that's
something that anyone watching this
assumes if anyone watching this is like
I'm a gamer I play games devs don't play
games
that is something I think that people
are putting on themselves as like
another ring tactic they're looking at
why don't this other person is different
than me how what's a line of difference
I can find with that person
I don't think there's because there's no
evidence the game devs don't play games
there's a lot of evidence that they do
the contrary yeah we're constantly
stealing other people's ideas
just like there's so many I'm there with
my little with my little games I am I
think I edited this out of the video too
it's like if you have programming skills
and you want to be a programmer you're
not going to [__] do it in Game Dev
unless you like this video no one gets
this is the other thing no one gets is
how much better off any Game Dev would
be so much more money any other industry
I had I've got a friend who's a
programmer in the financial in the
fintech sector like makes like banking
software
um I think actually maybe listen to the
show hey Sam
um but like is into games and has like
uh you know occasionally said like can I
like could I get into games like and and
I was like yeah no absolutely I'm sure
there's loads to earn and he asked me
what the average salary was yeah like
there's a there's like there's surveys
and stuff you can look at so I brought
up on my phone like that's the regular
code of salary education and the guy was
like I
well no yeah
so you know everyone who's here is here
because they're passionately interested
in entertaining people with video games
but but if someone doesn't want to if
someone I don't think that wins any
arguments I don't think anyone who's who
was listening to this who's like they're
not real Gamers those people are not
going to be won over by that argument
because they don't want to be won over
by that argument and everyone who
instinctively understands that probably
people who make games are into games
isn't sending harassment to people on
Twitter because they don't like
something in a game a decision made by
someone five runs up the ladder from the
person that you're talking to I feel
like I'm I'm not even really addressing
the the people who are responsible for
the harassment because like
there's always going to be keyboard
Warriors we can't fix that problem
to everyone else exactly and and it's
it's that there are loads of people who
are like
frustrated about video games
um
that have this divide that I again I
just always feel like if we if we were
more unified in like
imagine the world where again I said
that this in a video the game for today
the game is all are on this because I so
often think that that's true and you
just not know is it the gamers are on
the same side as the dev team that's
I've seen that happen especially with
the uh delays conversation if you
entertainment delay is announced I'm I'm
impressed by how many people are
replying to that going take your time
that's true and that's a sort of reason
I think that go through that has gotten
better but there's a there's a lot of it
like
I I have a few friends who work on very
micro transaction heavy life service
games and a few friends who work on
mobile games yeah and we've all done it
well actually in those instances
the mobile game specifically is like I
have again a few friends who work at a
specific Studio making
money raking mobile games and I was like
how is that like do you have trouble
doing that and they were like I worked
at Studios that didn't pay me and people
yelled at me for a really long time and
then I just wanted to support my family
after a while it's like
damn okay but like it's not like they
are ever going to advocate for
exploitative microtransactions that's
not a thing that the dev team is asking
for under any circumstances no one is
asking to do that
um but the audience is paying for that
so therefore yes capitalism kicks in at
that point I um I think that is a Nuance
that's interesting and
it doesn't it doesn't counteract what
you're saying about uh game does playing
games but one thing that I think is
interesting is
I definitely know game developers who
enjoy making games a lot more than they
enjoy playing them like there's
definitely an interesting that is a
different skill I used to work with
um actually it's the guy who drew this
picture of Megatron above my head I used
to over the concept artist who never he
never played video games didn't play
didn't care for video games at all but
just really liked [__] drawing the
coolest nerd sci-fi art you've ever seen
do you want to tell him to not make your
games look pretty because he doesn't
play video games as much as you there's
a lot of people working games who I work
with somebody who doesn't play games at
all
um and it's I think I've said this on
the show before but I find it valuable
uh that their input is very like doesn't
understand games community
doesn't like doesn't know popular
cultural touch points
um but it means we get a perspective
that's very fresh and like not at all
jaded and sometimes like they'll be like
they'll pitch something that we're like
well we can't that would just be this
game and they're like oh my bad someone
did that that's cool and that's the
other thing that I think goes over a lot
of people's heads and this is this is
something we definitely do wrong in
terms of how we communicate our games
are made like games are made by teams so
that person's presence on the team if
that person was making every decision
about the business model for your
upcoming first party game that would be
bad because that person doesn't know how
the industry Works they don't know how
what Gamers expect they don't know
anything about that stuff but that
person is part of a team so therefore
they're bringing something and as you
say if something is a little off track
you then the team kind of pulls it back
in and I think that's I think we as an
industry like we have vario tour focused
in terms of how we communicate about our
work and just kind of emphasizing that
team emphasizing and I I know I run
Bittle games so I I'm always on I want
to live when I go down this road but
like emphasizing the group I think helps
a lot with that because it also
emphasizes that because you you see it a
lot don't you in in like oh this I don't
like this thing in a game so that must
have been made by the one visible woman
who's on that team that that come around
a bunch of different times stuff like
that
things in Ragnarok that people didn't
like I have this thing saved that I was
like should I tweet this one day
um
yeah I'm happy to podcast it I have this
because this is happening for a long
[__] time and I have this is
18 screenshots that I never did anything
with and I've not spoken about
um the first one they all say the same
thing
the first one is so according to David
Jaffe atreyus is coming out as bisexual
on the next God of War I blame this gray
head feminist [__] for it may you rot in
hell
there are 18 of these where people are
blaming me
because they thought atreus was going to
be bisexual or trans
um
because of something David Jaffe
no and and I would have nothing to do
with it and David Jeffrey doesn't work
at the studio
the whole thing was like you literally
saw me and went that one like I had one
that's what I I think I kept the
screenshots because I thought about
tweeting it would have been ingest to
Jaffe I would have he'd find it
hilarious I imagine I was going to Tweet
all of them and be like
like any comment did you stay with Jeffy
dude did you have anything to say about
this but uh I was like I'm gonna leave
that one because the comments uh the
tweets uh the the comments and tweets
are so aggressive that I was like people
are gonna think I'm serious and it's not
something that I actually really care
about saying what there's right I was
like let me just leave that to itself
but it's like yeah again like that
doesn't make any sense if you know any
of the decision making process that goes
into a video game but yeah I think I
just walked in and went and he's gay now
because of my haircut like it's insane
it's insane I'm so aware is is
unreasonable what are they saying that's
not and also the person who left that
comment the one that I read is geralt of
Rivia with a picture of geralt decept
profile picture who is the reason that I
dyed my hair that color like I literally
I was like Daryl gray girl is great I
tried to be the same thing that
yellow-wide
literally he's looking at the
inspiration for the hair color in his
own [__] username
um you know that certainly happens and
again the talking about harassment is
something that I it's like it sucks but
I it's almost boring to say it sucks I
could yeah I could sit down that dude
and I could do I'm assuming a dude
that's maybe unfair but it was
definitely a dude I mean I could sit
down that seat for like half an hour and
explain the methodology by which choices
are made on AAA game about key story
built beats and character uh elements
and designs I could sit down I could do
all of that but it wouldn't change the
fact that he wanted to be mean to
someone on the internet like that's
that's something
they're separate issues and he's right
all I really do at work is just walk
into meetings and say and they're gay
now what if they're gay my whole jobs
have just like and what if everybody's
gay
yeah you've streamlined it now that
you've just got a little sign you hold
up you got me there
and everyone's gay
there are a lot of people on the
internet that are not worth replying to
and it's a bummer like there's stuff
that like
I think it took me a really long time to
figure out that um well you're you're
naturally uh Communicator you want you
you want to help people understand this
kind of stuff and now unfortunately it's
not doable in every as you well know
that's not doable in every situation
there are some things that like
um I'm sure I would have spoken about
this before one of the biggest
challenges of like
having any kind of following is people
will lie about me all the time and I
just have to let them and that was a
really tough thing because it's like I
want to correct all of them and there
are even some things that I've read that
I still think about that I would have
seen two years ago that I was like
didn't correct that I should have
corrected that one like no I should not
it doesn't make any sense you just kind
of have to let them because a they won't
believe you B they just want attention
and C there are too many lies to correct
you have to just let people lie about
you and it's so
brutal to watch people believe
this random person saying whatever they
want and being like Oh really she did
that like no that didn't [__] happen
at all but I just have to be like
all right and there's stuff that I would
love to address sometimes if like people
are mad at me for something that I
didn't do or say but I recognize that
most of those people don't care about
what actually happened they care about
me imagine the scale that you have I've
I've got a couple this one guy who I
talk to an event like 15 years ago you
know 10 years ago and I was desperate
for a piss so I kind of talked to him
quite briefly before rushing on and that
guy occasionally I'll just see like
complaining about how I'm aloof and how
old how you have two minutes to talk to
me when I saw him it's like dude I
really [__] needed a piss
um yeah but there's no point really
replying to that it's like okay exactly
I'm now just doing it on the podcast
which is very stupid but um not the
thing I regret most saying on this
yeah it can be tough and like that and
then you blow that up to
an entire game Studio I don't know I
just that's probably part of what leads
me to want to have this conversation is
like I'm not happy with the current
landscape of US versus them with the
three pillars of the games industry I
just don't there has to be a solution I
just don't know what it is I think I
think on the dev side which is the only
side I'm qualified to have an opinion on
for me it's just about being pulling
back a little bit in terms of my
communication when I'm talking about our
work it's very careful and glibber which
honestly also is better for a game like
what we're working on where we have big
partners and you know we can do things
in a more organized way
um that's careful not to mislead people
even if you have even if you're well
intentioned like again even if it's not
a lie if it's wrong and it's the same
thing really first Do no harm right
Hippocratic Oath stuff I think that's I
think for me that's that's the that's
the way that I'm approaching all of this
now and in terms of Gamers and
journalism I think I think on the whole
things are I I see much more journalism
these days than I love than that
irritates me so I think things are going
in the right direction there but um yeah
I think I agree and I think that
journalists
do
try hard to bridge the gap
um I don't think it's for lack of effort
it's just I I don't know maybe I'm being
like like fairy tale levels of naive is
like we're all here because we love
video games
why are we yelling each other the only
people who don't care about video games
are like the mega corporate suits
who don't have to listen to a squabble I
do think unfortunately the one the one
element
unfortunately
anger continues to be a very powerful
Financial Center for a lot of people who
talk about games yeah that's that's
unfortunately that that incentive
unfortunately I think colors a lot of
the conversations because you are
yeah like anyone who's watching this
like who's interested in what we're
talking about they're immediately
Googling
uh you know Baldur's Gate 3 controversy
right or how just to see like what are
they talking about what's the thing
they're referencing so that's driving
clicks to people who've talked about
this too and the person who's got the
most interesting thumbnail of them
roaring down the lens is going to get
the most of those clicks like it's just
it's a machine and unfortunately our
anger does
anger is currently incentivized by the
way people interact with the internet
especially the nature currently where we
all engage with the internet via like
three platforms yeah so everyone is
competing for eyeballs in the same
places it means that it's there is a
drive towards that kind of aggressive
content that is what this that is the
stuff people click on I find myself you
do this like when I'm watching when I'm
scrolling through like my YouTube
homepage
I will click on a video without thinking
and it will go into something that is a
bit angry and I'll have to I'll like
shake out and be like oh no I don't want
to watch a drama video about something
that like I don't know or care about but
but it was engaging because I saw in a
mo the thumbnail showed emotions I went
to see what was going on I was intrigued
by someone I saw yelling in them all you
know I don't do that because I don't
watch YouTube which is one of my
weirdest uh habits that's worse than the
game developer I know way worse uh but
no I I I I don't watch YouTube content
the only stuff that I will watch which
is like the most pretentious thing in
the world to say but it's also true is
like a
uh documentary
um I started watching this one channel
that makes these documentaries that I
wish I can remember the name of the
channel um and I watch some stuff that
Rahul will watch so I'll watch it with
him like we watch nukes top five he's
just like terrible
Terrible's not the right way to put it
sorry Duke uh he does Ghost video
compilations and then infuriate us right
um
yeah lots of Warhammer painting actually
shout out to Luton
this uh
channel that makes like historical
videos but they do all like it it looks
like a comic book like or they do all
their own art and then just narrate over
the top but it's I'm a big fan of that
um but no I do sometimes have trouble
with
Rahul consumes a lot of content he also
consumes some of the angry content and I
will sometimes be like oh my [__] god
turn this off like I heard something the
other day that I was like
holy [__] they just like every word was
the M she her uh because they just
so obnoxious but it's also sometimes
that uh it doesn't take that many beats
of those videos before you can hear
somebody talk about me which has
happened twice where I've been like
they're gonna I'm gonna get brought up
in this video and then I do and I'm like
I don't want anything to do please take
this I don't want anything to do with
any of this please take this away from
me like
the
thread of like angry
I mean it's like and I'm so small but
it's still not that hard to get there
like it's I don't want anything to do
with it so you're definitely a nosy for
those kind of douchebags and I'll be
I'll be honest like the thing for the
thing that I like is YouTube seems to
get me enough I don't get served the
really awful stuff I'll get served to be
this Star Wars movie was less good than
we anticipated video sure and then just
it'll have like a throw away thing so
there's quite a lot of women in these
now it's like oh oh no that's the white
line they're starting to yeah it gets
you know they're pretty fast yeah there
was one that uh Rahul fell asleep in
autoplayed that I had to turn off the
other day and I'm not gonna name
any of the details because they will
make a video about me
um where
like every two minutes it was basically
word for word women are [__] stupid
like like so frequently like oh big
strong powerful women these days idiots
like it just kept happening to the
extent that I was like oh my God
so frequently just like pivoting the
videos often as possible to I hate women
in a way that I was like I I thought
that this wasn't quite that real like I
think I had expected that it was more of
like like this is like we exaggerated
I've seen stuff
exaggerated they're not they don't just
yell the women they're stupid surely
yeah it was so frequent that that was
like it's not even relevant here to
blame women
I don't think I don't think you can
battle that on the algorithm I think
that stuff is so clickable and so that
rabbit hole might go anywhere like I
remember we were working on um we're
working on John Wick I had to Google a
lot I had to go and I had to search I
ended up ended up like doing private
tabs and stuff because I had to search a
lot for like footage of guns being shot
because for reference like we were
looking at like how the animation and
stuff of guns being shot and you look at
two videos of a gun range and you start
getting suggestions that are
astonishingly yeah it happens fast that
pipeline all it takes is a you know a
teenage boy who's a bit angry because
the girl he likes won't talk to him who
clicks on a video for dating advice and
two videos later they're seeing it sells
yeah it happens very very quickly it's
uh
don't consume content that makes you mad
that's the biggest thing is like if it
makes you mad they're profiting off of
that and it's just bad for your heart
like literally a heart help it's just
bad for you just get out of there um and
I definitely wish people would do that
more often as well otherwise I don't
know I we need Solutions I think to the
communication problem but I think that's
the solution I think definitely one of
them don't watch stuff that makes you
angry
um yeah if you feel yourself getting
angry literally click away if it's a PR
if there are many problems in this world
that will affect you directly and the
people you care about directly worry
about those issues work on those issues
but don't don't get yeah if someone who
tells you may know all the answers
always trying to make you angry is
definitely profiting off you currently
so don't let them yeah that's so easy to
do so easy to do so easy
um alrighty on that note I'm a lot of PS
I'm a video game writer That's Mike but
he's a video game director this is play
watch listen
uh we are not recording next week or at
least I'm not
even awesome
probably not being awesome me and Austin
trying to schedule a call in load up
yeah good luck have fun with that
uh we'll see you guys not next week the
week after maybe hopefully probably
hi
[Music]